[Musique]
les malheureux jpy sont en train de
vieillir ils deviennent gras et bouffi
pour ce faire maigrir il faut de la
gymnastique et suivent des traitements
spécialisés et jbe pompe de jeunes qui
n'avaient plus d'amis pour lui faire de
la musique s'était mis lui aussi à faire
du vélo
les shadoks de la nuit pompey est aussi
soi disant pour le cuir intelligent et
la terre pour suivre le mouvement
général elle aussi tournait sur place il
n'y avait que le bas-rhin shadow qui
continuaient à venir joyeuse vie et qui
ne pompe est pas tellement
[Musique]
les matelots shadow que s'adapter petit
à pied leur nouvel élément et se
transformer chacun selon son coût qui
ont shadoks requins qui ont shadow crabe
mou château comme à riom shadoks haddock
et tout ce petit monde patauge elle
attend at il mieux les paquets à ses
occupations habituelles
tout cela bien entendu se passer sous
l'eau évidemment pour que ça fasse plus
vrai on aurait pu mettre des algues du
rocher et une plus des quantités de lait
chaud sous marine de cet acabit mais
pour nous vous comprenez ça ferait du
travail nos téléspectateurs sont quand
même assez grand pour s'imaginer tout
seul que cela se passe sur l'autre et de
toute façon cela ne ferait rien la
vérité de notre histoire il n'y avait
que la shadow caravelle qui
malheureusement n'était pas très habitué
à tout ça et il fit commencé à battre de
l aile pour ainsi dire évidemment les
shadoks aurait pu tout bonnement la
laissions plomb et continuer à pied ou
par n'importe quel autre moyen de
transport sous marins plus approprié
mais voyez-vous dans la marine même sous
marines et des choses qui se font pas
alors pour ne pas qu'elles se gâte les
maths l'on avait mis leur chat d'oc
caramel dans une grande bouteille et l'a
ramené à la surface de temps en temps
pour d'échangés sont m
pour la nourriture et bien c'était
facile les marins shadox ou loire est à
la pêche et quand arrivé le week-end ils
allaient tous se reposer à gégène pitch
et danser le charleston jusqu'à une
heure très avancée de l'adie
[Musique]
et